you
go ahead oh okay I see how you happened
I have naturally hits God broadcasting
okay
hi I'm Jana bdellium CEO of pin dark we
are based in Raleigh North Carolina
currently bracing for hurricane Florence
here the noble rapid microbiology method
we are presenting here came about during
another famous Hurricane Katrina at that
time my partner Jeff old who is an
engineer was actively involved in their
surveillance of the flooded areas as you
remember the flood caused massive damage
to the coastline and a spread of
water-borne bacterial infections
existing testing methods were just too
slow for effective response so Jeff came
up with the rapid method leveraging
existing low-cost technology and luckily
DDD turned out to be the perfect
platform for us to test this new
approach it has the appropriate data
resolution and a suitable overall
mechanical structure that allowed us to
successfully perform proof-of-concept
testing with live bacteria the
fundamental principle of this patent
patent pending on technology is that the
presence of immobilized particles such
as bacteria on the surface of a digital
encoded substrate such as an optical
disc scatters light and prevents the
optical drive laser from reading the
data at that location producing errors
in proportion to the quantity of targets
present one innovative aspect of this
technique is that we figured out a way
to directly isolate microbial targets on
the data surface for rapid optical
detection without culturing
amplification or costly chemical
patterning so determination of target
presence or absence and approximate
concentration can be accomplished in a
few minutes the SI assembly is designed
to be hermetic and does not contaminate
the optical drive another transformative
aspect is that while the use of the
low-cost commercial device has enabled
an easy path towards providing proof of
concept this bio detection technique is
not restricted to the use of an optical
disk drive as the system fundamentally
any digital storage platforms that could
support the physical presence of a bio
entity while being read could be applied
in this method that includes some types
of digital media that have very high
resolution and are therefore capable of
detecting small
or entities such as viruses proteins etc
we've been collaborating with the
University of North Carolina Chapel Hill
water Institute on testing our current
prototype project that you see here on
the poster with various concentrations
of live ecoli cells based on our
preliminary tests we anticipate
achieving method sensitivity and
specificity above 90% potentially close
to 100% with sample processing times
under five minutes and cost per test
about 10 times lower than the current
industry-leading rapid molecular
techniques our current roadmap is to
validate the performance of the
technique for one or two bacterial
species clinical concern and sexually
transmitted infections appear to be good
targets for market entry ultimately for
improved usability and point of care and
field applications the device design
will be miniaturized automated and
possibly multiplexed we are open to
collaborations and partnering and very
interested to explore various use cases
for our rapid technique thank you so
much for your interest and attention and
I'm looking forward to hearing from you